hmm
yeah yeah i'm sure the birds are really
impressed but once you finish showing
off you think you might concentrate on
some actual
work getting celeste in position for a
handoff
you need to get the delivery she'll be
near the communications tower
of power
you're taking your sweet old time
celeste's getting pissed she's almost at
the cops tower and you ain't
get moving give her the bag cell will
take it from there
ah
wires are fizzing about you faith sounds
like some blues are headed your way
news chopper tipped them off
ah
crazy get out of there mate
i'm patching celeste you there so what
the hell
i can hear gunshots and that bird seems
a little too curious
faith on her way get your ass ready to
move
drop the bag and put your hands where we
can see them get the hell out of there
wires are going crazy get out of there
her way get your ass ready to move
you're gonna have to get through
uh
clues ahead you're gonna have to get
through
get to celeste there are more blues on
the way
come on faith cps on youtube hey throw
me the bag
okay i got it from here okay they're
playing rough cell
i'll be fine
you gotta get off that roof bait don't
care how you do it just do it
get to celeste there are more blues on
the way
get to celeste there are more blues on
the way
come on
you gotta get off that roof face don't
care how you do it just do it
[Music]
this is about to be a low-key job why
the hell were they shooting
get your ass back to base
you